we currently understand very little
about the human brain
do you also hope that the work at
neuro-link will help us understand more
about our about the human mind about the
brain yeah the work in your like will
definitely shut a lot of insight into
how the brain the mind works right now
just the data we have regarding the how
the brain works is very limited
we've got fMRI which is that that's kind
of like putting us you know a
stethoscope
on the outside of a factory wall and
then putting it like all over the
factory wall and you can sort of hear
the sounds but you don't know what the
machines are doing really yeah it's hard
you can refer a few things but it's very
porous road in order to really know
what's going on in the brain you really
need you have to have high precision
sensors and then you want to have
stimulus and response like if you
trigger a neuron what how do you feel
what do you see how does it change your
perception of the world you're speaking
to physically just getting close to the
brain being with the measure signals on
the brain
yeah will give us sort of open the door
inside the factory yes exactly being
able to have high precision sensors that
tell you what individual neurons are
doing
and then being able to trigger a neuron
and see what the responses in the brain
so you can see the consequences of if
you fire this neuron what happens how do
you feel what has change
it'll be really profound to have this in
people because people can articulate
their change like if there's a change in
mood or if they've you know if they can
tell you if they can see better or hear
better or be able to form sentences
better or worse or you know their
memories or jogged or that kind of thing
you